next author Ted nice discusses his book
gangs of America the rise of corporate
power and the disabling of democracy
it's just over an hour good morning
again and glad to see you all here on
this beautiful spring day it's just
glorious outside and I am tickled to
death this morning to be able to
introduce a brand new friend of Ted nace
who has come all the way from Berkeley
California to be with us this morning
and last week I finished his book and I
want to tell you it's one of the most
captivating books that I've read in a
long long time and at the beginning when
it deals with a lot of legal stuff it's
a little heavy going but being a lawyer
by training I waded through it all and
and it's the last part and I'm sure
you're going to be hearing mostly about
that this morning talks about this whole
question of corporate power and how how
it got started and how it's really
disabling our democracy in many respects
I'm very pleased this morning also to
welcome a father and mother mother of
Ted who were sitting right up here and
I've known Ted for four or five years
now and in other areas of work they grew
up and they were brought up in North
Dakota and after that Ted went off to
school and Stanford and did things with
the Environmental Defense Fund community
organizing and then ended up in still in
California working on computer a
computer I think was Macworld he started
was that are working for them and made
quite a name for himself there and
eventually ended up starting a
publishing company called peach
tip press this is hard to come out with
but and it was quite successful other
words so successful in fact that he
decided to sell it and the end his
entrepreneurship and and so that
prompted him to go back and and really
discovered how the corporate world
really got started in America so dad
come on up and share with us your thank
you very much jack that was really nice
introduction and let me get my 47 pages
of notes here lock the doors nobody gets
out alive yeah and I got a chance to sit
in your service it was a wonderful
service and I really appreciate the
invitation to come here and it's a it's
a privilege to talk to you and it's nice
to have my folks here and not I get this
this time interrupted uninterruptedly a
little louder huh let's see
how's that is that better not yet ok I'm
going to raise it up a little is that
better ok let's get started well as Jack
said I've spent I've spent a good deal
of time in the business world myself and
you know every day in business you face
ethical choices it's just no doubt about
it every single day and I gave my talk
yesterday at the borders bookstore and
the first person raised their hand they
said you know you gave your whole talk
but didn't say anything about the gangs
look why do you call corporations gangs
it's a really good question the basic
answer is a gang is a business
enterprise you know you can hear Tony
Soprano talking about himself as a
businessman the gang is an illegal
business enterprise a corporation is a
legal business enterprise but there's a
there's a little bit there's a little
bit of another of another element in
society in terms of thinking about
business enterprise and that's the
question of legitimacy you know a gang
isn't just illegal it's illegitimate and
the question of whether corporations and
the power that they wield is legitimate
or not is is actually a pressing
question right now and there's a couple
of indications of that I mean even
before the Enron scandal and all the
other scandals that went along with it
there were concerns about corporate
power to the extent that Businessweek
devoted an entire issue to the subject
of corporate power back in the year 2000
so just before the election and they ran
a poll and they asked this
question do you agree with the statement
business has big business has too much
power in Washington well or do you think
big business has too little power in
Washington well five percent of the of
the people they surveyed said they
thought big business had too little
power in Washington seventy-four percent
said big business had too much power and
then they asked a different question
they said do you think business has too
much power over too many aspects of our
lives smarter sort of focusing on the
personal realm and the numbers went up
even higher eighty-two percent of people
said they felt business has too much
power over too many aspects of our lives
that's sort of a challenge to the
legitimacy of the corporation another
another way of measuring that has to do
with just just dollars and cents and I
get these figures from Paul Krugman who
is an economist who recently wrote an
article called the death of Horatio
Alger a lot of that article was about
statistics showing changes in social
mobility in the United States especially
in the last 30 40 years it was very
disturbing because prior to the 1970s
there were a much higher percentage of
people who moved from within their
lifespan from the lowest 25% group into
the top 25% so this Horror Show Alger
story was literally something that you
could find pretty commonly since then
that that that opportunity has gone down
there are fewer people moving from one
group into another into the higher group
from the lowest group into the highest
group more specifically the economic
fate of everybody basically well not
quite everybody he was talking about the
lowest ninety percent of the population
the real income of the lowest ninety
percent of the population since 1973 has
dropped by seven percent well that's a
little bit confusing because we know
that the economic output
per person in the United States economy
in that same period went up by thirty
percent and you know in the 60s by the
60s America had basically arrived at the
status of a middle class society
post-world war two the 50s and 60s were
a period of a lot of economic growth and
and most of the country was middle class
but since that time real incomes have
gone down well with output going up per
person and by the way economic output
per household in this country now is
ninety thousand dollars a year so we
really have the wherewithal to not just
be a middle class society but also to
solve a lot of social problems but
that's not what's happening and and I
don't know if you remember the phrase
used by the first president Bush he
talked about he said the fact is as a
society we really have more will than
wallet it was sort of his apology or his
way of explaining why we can't spend
more money on social programs we have
more will than well actually we actually
have quite a lot of wallet but where did
the money go well the top 1% of the
population did much better the top ten
of a percent did better than the top one
percent and the top 100 of one percent
according to krugman's figures which
were taken from congressional budget
office numbers and ultimately from the
Internal Revenue Service the top of one
hundredth of one percent had gone up
since 1973 by five hundred ninety-nine
percent six-fold well that presents a
question of legitimacy and the reason is
that we all know that business is not a
you know it's not a sunday school my
metaphor would be its kind of like a
locomotive locomotive is pulling society
up a long slow incline and we're all
being pulled up with it maybe some
people are sitting in better seats than
others but people will basically put up
with that because everybody's moving
upward and that was really the the sort
of the social contract that's sort of
the deal that has made
most people feel that corporate power is
legitimate you know where maybe we get a
little smoke maybe we get a little noise
but let's be realistic we've got a very
powerful engine pulling this society
what the what the Krugman figures show
is that the locomotive has kind of come
a little bit detached that them that the
locomotive still chugging up the hill
but the rest society's starting to drift
back down the hill well the question of
legitimacy really comes to comes to the
fore when you have a situation such as
what happened two years ago when
suddenly it turned out that the that the
chief financial backer of the of the
president Ken Lay was the head of a
company that turned out to be pretty
deeply corrupt and that as that scandal
unfold whose sudden we had other
scandals too now in a way i think i saw
these scandals unfolding as I research
my book and in a way I looked at them as
not really the indication of a deep
problem of the corporation in our
society I mean these were sort of
battles of the haves against the haves
because it was basically you know as
more and more scandals unfolded it was
basically CEOs stealing from
shareholders and even though even though
ownership of shares of corporations has
broadened in our society still most of
the wealth is owned by that top 1% of
the population about forty three percent
actually so that the top one percent
owns more of the financial wealth of the
core of Corporate America than the
bottom say ninety even more than ninety
percent so really essentially those
scandals were the haves versus the
halves with a lot of collateral damage
along the way a lot of a lot of heard
employee is a lot of disappointed
pension holders but those scandals
motivated President Bush to make a
speech about the problems in corporate
America and it's interesting what he
actually said
he said basically that corporations in
his opinion had become disconnected from
the values of our country he said that
too many corporations seem disconnected
from the values of our country and he
went on to denounce quote-unquote
destructive greed destructive greed
basically a kind of a call to more
traditional morality destructive greed
sort of you know kind of rolls around in
my head as an idea because you know the
whole point of the corporate system is
the idea that greed can be harnessed as
something good so what he's really
saying is there's kind of a good greed
and then there's like a bad greed it
went constructive greed we don't want
destructive greed well that's you know
that's useful and I actually think it's
pretty profound as people in our own
lives we know the difference I think you
know we're not again we're not angels in
our everyday lives we all pursue our
self-interest that's not a bad thing we
have to draw the line and not go
overboard and be destructively greedy
but we like to look at our mutual funds
and see them going in the right
direction okay so um and I think that's
you know that's a problem that we've
wrestled with as a culture for thousands
of years it you know it's built into the
Ten Commandments you know just sort of
where you draw the line well it doesn't
say exactly but it says you should at
least try the problem with applying this
to the corporation is that the
corporation is is a distinct break from
traditional enterprise a traditional
enterprise was family business
partnerships businesses where the owners
of the business were closely identified
and generally the same people as the
people running the business
accountability and benefits were all in
one place but the invention of
Corporation which was in the late 1500s
when groups of British merchants had to
get enough capital together to put out
to put big expeditions to get ships
equipped and send them overseas as far
away as the East Indies where the
chances of success of any given voyage
were pretty small so they had to pool
their money they had to pool their risk
and they came up with this idea of joint
stock and over time they came up with
other ideas too but the idea of limited
liability limited liabilities just a way
another way of saying if I own stock in
something I don't have to lie awake at
night worrying that someone might sue
the company that I own stock in and
suddenly I lose my house I might lose my
my stock the company might go bankrupt
but nobody can come after me for more
than that that's that's limited
liability another thing they built in
the corporate structure was immortality
so that you know if if the owner died or
the manager died the enterprise could
still go on we sort of what all these
things are to disconnect the corporation
from individual living breathing human
beings that was intentional that was a
that was a way of making this economic
engine more powerful more versatile more
flexible the idea that a corporation
wouldn't have a body that it could split
into two pieces or the two pieces could
merge is hard to do that with family
businesses the idea that a corporation
wouldn't wouldn't have to have a
particular home you know you could be
incorporated here and operate there you
know the English legal philosopher Baron
thurlow summed it up like this he said
corporations have no soul to damn they
have no body to kick these were all you
know pretty innovative things and they
were all intentional but they all make
it kind of hard to actually implement
this idea of President Bush of
distinguishing between destructive greed
and good greed good greed is the is
the gasoline in the engine and when you
just have greed as the as the as the
primary organizing principle you know
say for designing a car that would be
the equivalent of designing a car for
maximum speed as your only criteria I
mean you know think about what kind of
car that would be it would be great in a
straight straight away race and there's
cars that are designed that way but it
really wouldn't be that good of a car in
general that's kind of what we've done
with corporate and it's not just really
a way we've designed them over time in
general it's actually became a legal
requirement in 1919 very interesting
case called Ford vs. Dodge Henry Ford
was the CEO of Ford Motor Company he was
the majority shareholder he was the
inventor of the assembly line he was the
chairman of the board there were two
brothers the dodge brothers they had
invested about ten thousand dollars in
ford motor company back in about 1910
and by 1918 they they they were starting
their own car company and they were
depending on the quarterly dividends of
ford motor s there as their chief source
of financing for for dodge well ford was
a little bit of a kind of a crazy
capitalist I mean he was motivated not
just by profit but by this vision had
this vision he wanted a Model T in every
driveway in America and he began to stop
paying out the dividends big fights at
the board meetings they took him to
court well in the court in court he
could have argued and he goes said well
you know this is my way of i forgot to
say what he want to do with the money he
was cutting the price of ford's so that
more and more people could buy them when
he got to court he could have said well
this is a this is a long-term strategy
for maximizing profits I'm building up
our base you know he could have said a
lot of things but before it was a really
a very straight shooter and he said you
know what I frankly really don't care
about profit I want to see more cars I
want to be known for put
car in every driveway in America well
the court said you know Henry Ford you
may have invented the assembly line but
on this one we're going with the dodge
brothers the sole criteria ultimately
for corporate decision making can only
be maximizing profit and that became a
legal tenant of corporate management
after 1919 well so we as a society have
kind of bought the car that can only go
fast but we know that that that's not
exactly you know the smartest thing and
this is not a this is not a new
realization I mean even before Ford
versus dodge corporations were run for
profit and people saw that that having
only the Prophet principle as the
criteria for corporate management could
be a problem so I want to mention a
couple of times in American history
where this problem has been grappled
with and some of the ways in which it's
been some of the responses that have
been developed and I call these sort of
transformative moments just to be
grandiose sort of crises of legitimacy
in the past and basic I'm going to talk
about two approaches one is sort of
putting things inside the corporation to
make it to make it nicer and the other
sort of putting things outside the
corporation to make it behave the first
instance was the Boston Tea Party and
the Boston Tea Party is an interesting
example of the haves versus the haves it
was sort of the the opening skirmish of
the Revolutionary War in fact in the
years preceding the Boston Tea Party
some of these super Patriots like Sam
Adams who really wanted something some
kind of revolt against Britain just
couldn't really get any any support
particularly from the business community
people didn't really like things that
you know there was a lot of grumbling
but there really wasn't anything
happening but what happen the late 1760s
that then sort of emerged as a
full-blown crisis in 1773 was at this
very large British company the East
India Company was
into a financial crisis East India
Company is really a remarkable thing
it's probably the most most the largest
single company that has ever existed in
terms of low any number of things it had
its own army it had an army twice the
size of the British Army 250,000 men and
they ruled India they there already 175
years old at that time and they had you
know gotten fat and a little bit lazy
and they had kept increasing their
dividends suddenly there was a famine in
India their production over there their
revenues over there weren't coming in
like they they normally would but even
more of a problem for the company was
that Europe went into a depression we
couldn't sell tea like they were used to
selling they had 12 million pounds of
tea sitting in warehouses in Britain and
they had a cash flow problem well they
always had the cooperation of Parliament
and parliament approved a scheme which
basically amounted to a franchising of
tea shops in the colonies they had been
seen their tea sales be sort of sapped
by Dutch black market tea but they were
allowed to cut that the Tea Tax at one
end of the pipeline and they were also
allowed to set up this system where in
order to sell tea in the colonies you
would have to be a East India Company
licensee well in all the larger cities
the tea merchants were upset by the plan
and particularly in Boston the governor
there was was very insensitive he
appointed two of his nephews and two of
his sons and one of his friends to have
the franchise's it was a real slap in
the face to people like John Hancock who
is of wealthy tea merchant basically
what the tea merchants did is they went
to the other members of the business
community in Boston and they said look
if they can do this to tea and just take
it over like this or they're going to
end up doing this to all of your
businesses eventually too and they were
convincing enough that the other
businessmen joined them basically those
people who who who dressed up like
Mohawk Indians on a winter's night in
1773 where the small
business people the merchants the trades
people of Boston and they ransacked the
ships well 13 years later there are 13
years after 1776 when the Constitutional
Convention met there was a debate about
corporate power on the one side was
Madison and Benjamin Franklin who were
very pro corporate Franklin was very
enamored of the idea of canals and he
wanted the government to create these
corporations that would build canals
like the Grand Canal in China that had
been the backbone of Chinese economic
development but most of the delegates
had been instructed by their home states
to vote against anything that would
empower corporations in the US
Constitution there was a standoff
between the two groups and so the
Constitution ended up not saying
anything about corporations the
Constitution gave freedoms to religion
it gave freedoms to the press but it
didn't say anything about corporations
specifically what happened was that the
states wanted to run corporations and
the state set up a system of individual
charters every corporation had to get a
charter you had to get a charter
charters individually from the
legislature and this was the idea that
they were going to internally sort of
program corporations to do that the
right thing they would have each
corporation declare a public service
mission and this public service mission
was was written you know right into the
right into the right into the the
charter of the corporation they limited
corporations to 20 or 30 year terms they
said that their physical home in their
legal home had to be the same they
couldn't own stock in other corporations
so you couldn't get this kind of a
strange thing happening where the
corporation that's doing something isn't
really the corporation that you're
dealing with legally they basically set
up a system that lasted for nearly a
century and was pretty successful the
only problem was that it was overwhelmed
in the late 1700s by the power of the
railroads and this whole system of
states writing in a public service
missions into corporations
and terminating the charter of the
corporation if the corporation
misbehaved all that was lost this thing
called general incorporation was was
initiated where basically you just go
down to the courthouse to the County
Clerk to start a corporation just file
some papers basically anything you want
to do with your corporation is fine well
that that has a lot more flexibility
means you can start an envelope company
but realize there's a better business
opportunity over here and you can you
can chase after all these things have
rational reasons and for a business
persons perspective all of them make
sense but collectively what they really
meant is that this this whole way of
controlling corporations internally
completely collapsed eventually that
ended up with another crisis and this
gets me to my second sort of moment of a
transformative moment the Great
Depression Franklin Roosevelt going into
the Great Depression there was already a
the same kind of crisis of legitimacy
that we have today in that one percent
of the population had had got the wealth
distribution had gotten skewed to the
point that one percent of the population
owned fifty percent of the wealth the
country as a whole had very few civil
liberties compared to now there were
social legislation was basically of all
kinds was often struck down as
unconstitutional there were judicial
doctrines that were very very looked
tenuously attached to the Constitution
it was one that it's taken me a long
time to understand by still don't think
I understand it but it's called
substantive due process a substantive
due process was a kind of a reading of
the contracts clause that says that
basically anything that an employer
wants to do with their employee as long
as both of them signed a piece of paper
is okay there the idea that it's really
not okay to say create a minimum wage or
to set a 40-hour workweek because
workers want to work like that that's
their business this sort of judicial
manifestation of the philosophy of
social Darwinism well all those things
preceded the Great Depression and in the
wake of the Great and the wake of the
Great Depression franklin roosevelt was
elected to office and pretty much the
mandate of roosevelt he made it very
clear in his camp
in 1932 he basically said I want to rein
in these these large corporations in
these large banks we can't just allow
the natural forces of the economy to to
make things come out right because they
don't necessarily come out right as we
can see right now the country is on its
knees we need the federal government to
proactively be involved in externally
controlling corporations to a certain
extent well that that that didn't rot
that didn't sit well with a lot of
corporate leaders and in 1934 there was
an attempted coup this is something I
don't know how many people have heard
about the attempted coup in 1934 I had
never heard about it myself but it's
documented in hearings of the house on
American Activities Committee from 1935
well what happened basically was that a
group of business men headed by a fellow
named Grayson Murphy he was ahead of a
Wall Street brokerage firm and a
director of Morgan guaranty as well as a
director of anaconda copper Goodyear
Tire and Bethlehem Steel another another
of these guys was named robert clark who
was a wealthy banker who had a 30
million dollar fortune and committed
half of his fortune to this plan another
person that got involved with was john
davis who had been the democratic
candidate for president in 1924 and was
now working as an attorney for for
morgan these businessmen were studying
the fascist movements in europe and they
sent mcguire over to europe and he met
with veterans organizations that were
connected to fascist organizations in
Italy and in Germany and in France and
he came back and he had the idea of
creating an organization that would be
similar to the French organization that
was called the Croix de foe and the
Croix de foe if I'm pronouncing that
correctly was sort of a umbrella
organization for veterans organizations
and their idea was that they would find
a suitable military leader who had the
respect of veterans organizations and
then they would confront the Roosevelt
administration they would ask the
Roosevelt administration to add a
position to cabinet that would be called
the secretary for General Affairs and
this general would be offered this post
they selected their general very
stupidly they picked a guy named Smedley
Butler and anyone heard of Smedley
Butler you know about his famous speech
they hadn't heard about the speech
Smedley Butler had been a very highly
decorated one of the only military men
in US history to receive the Medal of
Honor twice but he had had a major
change of heart about his activities in
that role because what up mostly what he
did was go over season put down small
countries that were showing some kind of
leftist streak or nationalistic streak
what have you Smedley Butler said said
this to the to the american legion
convention in connecticut in 1931 he
said i spent 33 years being a high-class
muscle man for big business for wall
street and the bankers in short i was a
racketeer for capitalism I help purify
nicaragua for the international banking
house of brown brothers in nineteen oh
nine to nineteen twelve i helped make
mexico and especially Tampico safe for
American oil interest in 1916 I brought
light to the Dominican Republic for
American sugar interest in 1916 I helped
make Haiti and Cuba a decent place for
national city bank boys to collect
revenue in I helped in the rape of half
a dozen Central American Republic's for
the benefit of Wall Street in China in
1927 I helped see to it that Standard
Oil when its way unmolested I had a
swell racket I was rewarded with honors
metals promotions I might have given Al
Capone a few hints the best he could do
was operate a racket in three cities the
Marines operated in three continents
well it's it seems anomalous to me that
they hadn't heard of his sort of
conversion but apparently they
heaven and they met with him in a they
met with him in the bell the Bellevue
hotel in New York and they laid out the
plan to him now they previously on the
very first meeting they're actually it
had been a meeting preceding this when
McGuire had laid out a number of a
thousand-dollar bills on a bed in
Chicago at a convention of the of the
American Legion and asked Smedley Butler
to make a speech that was basically a
certain probe business speechless medley
belt it was very discreet and he just
said you know I don't want to be I don't
take your money and he made the speech
that he intended to make but they were
really intent intent on recruiting him
and he played along with the plot and he
also recruited a general a journalist
named Paul French who collab who
corroborated a lot of the things that
the businessmen were saying to him you
know this may sound completely
unbelievable now but you have to
remember in the 1930s there was a lot of
pro-fascist sediment in the United
States it wasn't considered such a dirty
word in many circles many other circles
it was well basically what happened is
Smedley Butler blew the whistle he went
once he had enough documentation on the
plot he took the information to the
house on American Activities Committee
he testified and they broke up the plot
well you know it's it's it's it's a nice
vignette it shows what some the lengths
that some people will go to to keep
their power shows how upset people were
in business community with Franklin
Roosevelt but it's really not the only
way that that frankly that fascism can
happen there's also sort of a soft
fascism sort of a slow-motion
accomplishment of the same ends I'm not
saying that people in the business world
are fascists in fact I think they're
anything but fascists I think because
I've been in the business world that no
those are the kind of people that you
would have a babysit for you or
something it's not the individuals that
are the problem but the but as a whole
the logic of the corporation as business
people try to maximize profit they will
see all kinds of beneficial things as
obstacles and they'll try to get rid of
them
there's a very interesting definition of
fascism that a sociologist compiled
sociologist named Lawrence Britt he
published this a couple years ago and he
simply came up with a list of features
that he had seen in societies they had
become full-blown fascist societies like
like Italy and Germany and fascist Japan
and the list is 14 traits sort of you
can imagine a spectrum of fully
democratic to completely fascist that
these criteria would would tend to push
a society toward the fascist end of the
spectrum you know I feel like when I'm
saying that where it is almost like a
dirty word but it were trying to
describe basically society that's that's
not healthy that's not going in a good
direction and his his list was number
one nationalism number two disdained for
human rights number three preoccupation
with enemies and scapegoats number four
militarism five intensified sexism six
controlled mass media seven obsession
with national security aight religion
tied with ruling elite 9 protection of
corporate power 10 suppression of
organized labor 11 disdained for
intellectuals in the arts 12 obsession
with crime and punishment 13 rampant
cronyism and corruption in 14 fraudulent
elections
that was a you know that was just a
sociologist just can just just comparing
cultures and looking at cooking at some
traits that i believe that lives in two
thousand or no now I'm sorry 1998 1997
or 1998 Lawrence Britt oh good no it's
not in my book Lawrence Britt oh oh the
list them again they were nationalism
disdain for Human Rights preoccupation
with enemies and scapegoats militarism
intensified sexism controlled mass media
obsession with national security
religion tied with ruling elite
protection of corporate power
suppression of organized labor disdain
for intellectuals and the arts obsession
with crime and punishment rampant
cronyism and corruption and fraudulent
elections
now I talked about a change that
happened in America in terms of the
distribution of income starting in 1973
there was a parallel change politically
that started at about the same time and
I don't have time to really go into the
details but a fellow named Lewis Powell
became a secretary became a justice of
the Supreme Court but before he did that
he was a corporate attorney and very
very shortly before that he wrote a memo
to the Chamber of Commerce that became
kind of a rallying cry among business
executives in the 70s basically Powell
said that corporate America was in
trouble in fact he believed capitalism
itself was in trouble and maybe at that
time it seemed that that was true you
know those were the days when there was
widespread social unrest in the United
States and a lot of laws were being
passed that business people found
burdensome and they were burdensome on
business I mean they were they were
important laws that were that were that
were intended to significantly change
business one of the things that they
found very frustrating was a lot of
these laws were being enacted under a
Republican president and this is another
sort of flat you know flash to the Past
how different things are because these
are the laws that were passed under
Nixon and that Nixon actually supported
a repeal of the Kennedy era investment
tax credit imagine a Republican
president repealing an investment tax
credit today and increase in the capital
gains tax limits on the use of tax
shelters strengthened occupational
safety and health bill and tough new
regulations on air pollution you know in
dust two years alone 1969 and 1977 major
environmental and consumer groups were
formed major legislation was passed
National Environmental Policy Act Clean
Air Act Amendments a ban on cigarette
commercials canceling the funding of the
supersonic transport plane new agencies
the Environmental Protection Agency OSHA
the Consumer Product Safety Commission
Powell basically said that business has
got to do something about this stuff or
basically capitalism is over and that
the people promoting this stuff were
anti capitalist and what he proposed was
that business executives mobilized in a
new way politically and prior to this
business would go to Washington or
really rev up the lobbying machine when
they went had a particular need but what
he said his business has to form
permanent institutions in Washington to
advocate business interests collectively
and he said that the CEOs couldn't
delegate this job to their vice
president for legal affairs or
legislative affairs or you know that
they had to take it on personally okay
I'll wrap it up okay I'll wrap it right
up he formed in or he advocated the
formation of a group which which
actually was done a couple years later
called the Business Roundtable to be in
the business roundtable you had to be a
CEO of one of the top 200 companies well
this is part of a very large
mobilization of business that has really
shifted the politics and and I want to I
want to get two questions now but I want
to say just in ending that you know the
message I'm trying to leave you with is
not a message of hopelessness but really
one of hope and you know the reason is
that so much is at stake a lot of the
reason that corporate power tends to
expand during periods when it's not
being sort of under the spotlight is
because it's just the natural result of
a powerful institution flexing its
muscle again and again again in the
political realm and again you know as we
talked as I talked about earlier when
it's just a little bit of smoke and
noise coming in through the windows of
the train we're willing to put up with
that but right now the fate of the
planet itself is at stake and I don't
think I really need to elaborate on why
so I think this issue is coming into the
spotlight and I think that's a
constructive thing so let's stop now for
questions thank you
a little bit i mean the antitrust laws
are not being enforced they changed the
philosophy of it when we started getting
a lot of competition from Japan and the
idea was well they have really big
companies and we need big companies to
go up against their big companies it
used to be that a company in fact one of
the last times the supreme court upheld
a real breakup of a company that wasn't
one of the big companies was was in shoe
manufacturing and they actually didn't
allow a merger that would have given one
company five percent of the shoe market
well we don't have a shoe market anymore
and there's no shoe manufacturing
anymore in the United States so so the
climate shifted but now there's really
no antitrust enforcement or very little
at this point they're talking about
blocking the merger of two software
companies PeopleSoft and oracle and and
the problem is we would only have one
company in the United States creating
this kind of software so I guess they're
saying that maybe just one company isn't
is is it's too concentrated but they're
willing to put up with what they're
being just too
to have talked a little bit about person
corporation okay i'll give you the 3
minute version person personhood a
personhood is an old legal idea that
just means that an entity can come into
the courts and be recognized as a as a
person it just means that entity that
can be recognized by the courts in 1886
there was a famous case called the santa
clara decision and it was the first time
that corporations got recognition from
the supreme court as constitutional
persons means I at that point they were
they got one sort of protection of the
Constitution which was Fourteenth
Amendment protection the Fourteenth
Amendment you remember there was the
13th amendment that freed the slaves and
the 14th amendment that said they have
to be treated with a given equal rights
basically it was a particularly passed
because of the conditions that existed
in the states of the former Confederacy
after the Civil War but corporate
lawyers were creative people and they
said look we're legal people legal
persons and our stockholders are persons
and their rights matter and we need to
be treated on an equal footing with
every other legal person in society well
you know that sounds good there's
arguments for that there's also good
arguments against it the way the case
came down was very very very very
peculiar actually the Supreme Court just
justices who supported giving
corporations those rights walked away
from the that day disappointed because
the court decided in favor of the
corporation but only on technical
grounds and there was letters written
from one justice and others saying I'm
disappointed we didn't break new
constitutional ground but we didn't well
the way the court reporter wrote the
decision he just said right there in the
head the head notes to the decision
corporations are legal persons now that
have been something that I've been
kicked around verbally amongst the
judges but it wasn't part of the
decision well it became president and at
that time the Supreme Court was sort of
heading in that way anyway so they
didn't really have a problem with that
but the that is ironic that the
foundation of this whole body of
corporate rights happens to be a case
with such a shaky
foundation the real the real extension
of those rights came in the 1970s when
First Amendment personhood was given to
corporations there was a case in
Massachusetts where and it was upheld by
the Massachusetts Supreme Court state of
Massachusetts didn't want corporate
money in citizen referendums you know in
ballot measures and you know they had
reasons for that it was corrupting the
process they felt it was making ordinary
people feel they were shut out the
Massachusetts Supreme Court thought
those were legitimate reasons but the US
Supreme Court said no that it is really
not fair and it's not a good idea to try
to limit public debate and that when you
when you spend money in advertising even
on a ballot measure even if it's a lot
of money even if it's all coming from
one side you're still doing something
that we basically want to protect well
again there's good arguments on both
sides i think that i think the better
arguments are to allow campaign finance
reform to happen but that's what's
happened this this this doctrine of
corporations are persons that they enjoy
the same rights as persons has really
sort of mushroom to become a big problem
out there so why don't we start right
here yeah how would you have resolved
the Microsoft antitrust case how would I
have resolved the Microsoft antitrust
case you decide I I you know I don't I
don't really know um I I mean I know
there were proposals to split up
Microsoft into three parts and or into
two parts and you know I i I'm not
really a specialist on that stuff I i
mean i right I mean I I know that
Microsoft has made a lot of profits and
that the reason the profits are so high
is because they are in a monopoly
position they can charge a higher price
and they would if they had competition
you know I think Microsoft has said that
basically they're not in a perfectly
secure position that what could happen
you know to what they did to other
companies some new upstart could do to
them and maybe they're right about that
you know I know I guess I don't really
have an answer to that I'd be interested
in what
you have your thoughts on it yeah when
and how it became acceptable for CEOs to
receive these multi multi million dollar
salaries and severance packages even if
they haven't done very well and and
haven't even been with the company very
long it you know it really started
moving fast in the in the 80s that the
differentials gotten so big I mean just
compared comparing the United States and
other countries it's much much bigger
you know in the united states
approximately the average CEO of a
larger company earns 500 times the
average employee pay in in other
countries there's nothing like that in
the united states it wasn't like that it
was something I 25-fold which is a lot
500 times was kind of amazing well one
of the explanations is that economists
and CEOs kind of gang together and
tricked boards of directors and that the
trick was this they said wouldn't it
when wouldn't we stockholders make more
money if we could give an incentive to
the CEO to work harder well here's the
incentive if the stock goes up the CEO
is going to get a big bonus and but only
if the stock goes up well the problem is
if you really look closely at how large
corporations are run CEOs really run the
boards not the other way around so they
would create these incentives but then
if the stock would go down they'd move
the goalposts and that this really did
happen a lot so the incentive thing
ended up just being a you know just
being an easy way for CEOs to you know
to make more money and the interesting
thing is stock options don't appear on
art art it's not a requirement that
corporations show these stock options on
their balance sheet when they when they
file their taxes they have to show them
but when they show that their
performance to their investors they
don't show them so they can use them
when it's convenient to reduce their
profit to the government so they pay
less taxes but in in sort of displaying
their performance to their
shareholders they don't have to count
them as an expense so they've been able
to sort of keep two sets of books and a
lot of people in corporate America
itself think this is corrupt but a lot
of other companies want to keep doing it
so it still is still practice yeah oh I
understand what you're saying about
what's happening at the high end in
terms of the change in the distribution
of income but but you haven't shown us
how the at the lower end the that is say
the tenth say the comparison of the 10
percentile to the 50th percentile that
is the poverty end of is related to
corporate power yeah i mean i wish i had
that specific statistics two things that
one is the minimum wage has gone down in
real terms significantly the other is
that just the if you look at every sort
of quintile every twenty percent group
in society the lower you go the worse
off it's gotten you know necessarily
because of the what's happened in the
corporate structure because that
economists generally understand I know
you've said some nice things about
economies just a moment ago but anyway
they understand that that a big part of
the rising inequality is due to the stew
due to the skills gap no but look look
look at it in a little bit more of a
general way i would i would say look at
it in terms of social policy because a
lot of really if you want to look at
corporate power it also has to do with
decisions on education spending you know
on health care now you know Robert rice
makes this very good argument he's
saying you know if you really want to
encourage economic it develop in the
United States you don't cut taxes on
dividends because if you cut the taxes
on dividends you're increasing the
amount of money that can be invested but
it may not go into United States
companies what's the one asset of the
united states that you can invest in
that's not going to go overseas it would
be education and health care when you
have a healthier population you have a
more productive and a better educated
population ever more productive
population you can even apply that in in
and this is a recent article was about
what kind of environment is in the
United States for the very very highly
educated people who come over here from
China India and other countries well not
so friendly maybe right now as it was a
few years ago and those people are
starting to go to places like Vancouver
so if you look in the broad sense in
terms of social policy even even say a
very sort of defiant militaristic
approach to international affairs can
hurt America economically from when
xenian you know from a certain
perspective you are folk of doing
something about corporations from inside
and from outside and talk about why the
attempting to do it inside hasn't worked
on working on things on outside one
general proposition has been that there
needs to be a level playing field for
for corporations that if something is
going to affect one corporation it ought
to be equally across the others and
that's a matter of social policy and
getting either the Congress or the
states to pass the kind of either
controlling legislation or statements
and using the bully pulpit to get it to
go that way could you talk a little more
about how the corporations are
pretending that yeah let me give you a
really good example when I had my own
publishing company we you know we felt
guilty if we didn't use recycled paper
and so we started using recycled paper
well you know when you're when you're
making a profit and you know when you
feel like you you're feeling a you know
like a real good person you might make a
bold move like that but let's say say
you had a down year you might stop doing
it or if your competitors are
underpricing you you can't do it anymore
well when I got out of business I got
involved in this group that was trying
to promote the use of recycled paper and
they were signing up companies that
would pledge they would use thirty
percent of their 30 percent of books on
recycled paper well recycle paper
overall is a social good I mean if you
count all the benefits and all the costs
that you come out as it comes out as a
benefit for it for the individual
company it doesn't well small companies
were signing up large companies were not
if you talk to the people inside the
large companies that got
really interesting they'd all say we
really want to do this and they were and
I believe them we really want to do this
but we can't do this for two reasons our
competitors can't be unless our
competitors were required to do this we
can't do this because we would be
cutting into our profits we would have
to enter to someone upstairs and they're
not going to like this and I know
exactly what they're talking about it
has nothing to do with their morals it's
just the environment they're in so
that's an argument for why you actually
have to have recycled paper say a
standard a law or promote it by having
the government buy recycled paper or
something like this problem then is
pardon or at accident but the problem
then is corporate lobbyists will lobby
against that happening because even
though the people inside the company
wanted the lobbyists see it as their job
to fight for that and even if the
lobbyists wanted corporate America in
general will promote this ideology that
regulation is bad because regulation is
a problem for them it's it is a problem
for them there's no doubt about it you
can't sort of argue that regulation
isn't a burden on corporations so anyway
that's that's sort of the paradox and
the dilemma the problem is if you when
you really have a bad problem is when
you get enough say mobilize an
environmental movement you pass a lot
and then the Supreme Court declared
unconstitutional and that's what's so
going on with campaign finance reform
and other things too that's what
happened to you know minimum wage laws
until the Supreme Court sort of saw saw
the light you know when I feel the heat
I see the light that's what Everett
Dirksen used to say is it's a very good
sort of a rule of thumb about how even
even judges operate even though they're
not elected but it's true yeah I want to
put money back into the economic system
by moving toward the flat tax one step
at a time the first step is to eliminate
the mortgage interest tax deduction
seven that will put one trillion dollars
a year or more back into the tax system
70 million taxpayers own homes and or
have mortgages they may have one house
to house or even three houses 80 million
taxpayers do not own homes and have
mortgages but the whole
hundred and fifty million taxpayers must
pay for everybody's home that is bought
and sold that includes a mortgage
interest tax deduction and if the 70
million taxpayers only on one home I
have guesstimated that that will put one
trillion dollars a year for the rest of
our lives back into the tax system if
they own more than one home they'll get
more the budget deficit is 250 billion
dollars in three months eliminate the
mortgage interest tax deduction and that
budget deficit will be eliminated and
we'll be able to pay for social security
without gambling on the stock market
paper Medicare pay for the war etc
accepted wrote for the elderly on the
front burner of the presidential
campaign is the outsourcing of jobs
corporations that are sending jobs
overseas and there are many state not
many a few state legislators are now
passing laws saying if you operate here
you cannot send jobs there it's very
complicated issue I appreciate your
remarks on that topic yeah I mean I
think it's a you know it's just one of
those cases where democracy is working
you know and it's appropriate maybe it's
a bad idea maybe it's a good idea but
they're doing what you know they're
responding to the needs of people
corporate leaders like you know the head
of Hewlett Packard's you've said quite
openly we need to go overseas that's
where the educated people are it's a
sort of an illustration of why we need
to spend money on education in this
country but basically I think there's a
there's sort of a an ethos that has
grown up that the corporate world is not
our business that we shouldn't meddle in
it I think that's a good a good one to
get rid of yeah you know we might make a
mistake we might hurt our economic
growth you know this idea maybe it's a
good idea maybe it's not but if a bit if
enough people want it it'll become law
and we can try it out if it's a mistake
we can go back that
it's a great thing about democracy you
know and so I think that you know
Americans in general have become super
passive it's a bad thing it's like do we
have permission to regulate you you know
that's not the right attitude are you an
optimist or a pessimist as far as the
future of our economy well I'm an
optimist specifically that I think the
biggest economic problem to me
personally as I look at you know the
down the road it's that is this thing
called externalities yeah if you ever
heard the phrase externalities are all
the costs to society they don't actually
show up in the corporate balance sheet
this is how how you can sort of shove
your costs on to society pollution is
the easiest example stuff comes out of
my smoke stack it causes people to get
sick but I don't have to pay for their
medical costs we have a really very
pernicious problem in a industrial
society where everything is done in
these high-tech ways that caused all
these side effects well the side effects
could be could be dealt with a lot
better if we actually had two feet if
those same people who are producing the
side effects had to actually pay the
costs you know one of the one of those
things has to do with innovations of a
law there's this idea of tort the tort
is one of the basic rights of Western of
anglo-american law the tort simply means
I can if you damage me I can sue you the
reason that externalities like pollution
don't get solved in the civil courts is
because it's very hard to pin the blame
on a specific actor so if I suddenly
come down with emphysema who do I soo
what would be nice for example if there
was some legal innovations that allowed
the class of emphysema suffers to
somehow get compensated by the class of
those who benefit by creating pollution
there something like that was done in
the Superfund the Superfund was
basically a tax on all of the polluting
companies that had created toxic waste
sites and then they collectively would
pay for it well there's all that turned
out ideologically the Republican
administration really hated it
cuz they don't like to pay for the
externalities is the you knows it's a
it's a seen as an anti-business thing
they also had practical reasons for
thinking it was bad because it's
bureaucratically it's been often very
inefficient you know you get these sort
of gold-plated cleanups you know usually
when they have an objection they're
making their they have some good reasons
but I you know I still think we have to
have mechanisms like that I think that
as I said before as the problem to come
supercritical I think society who wakes
up and it basically starts to find
solutions you know the ozone layer it
was a classic example it was amazing how
fast society moved to limit the
production of fluorocarbons that were
killing off the ozone layer you know
once the scientific community really
coalesced around that global warming has
been much worse of a problem because the
big companies have so much at stake in
trying to deny the problem they actually
had a thing called the Global Climate
Coalition that was devoted to putting
out this information on global warming
well the scientific community is pretty
unanimous maybe not every single
scientist but the vast predominance of
scientific opinion saying that there is
a real problem here we have to do
something about you know the only
question is can we move fast enough but
you know there's a lot of examples where
it looked like a situation was hopeless
and then things change very quickly so
that's why you have to be optimistic
because there's so many examples of that
yes I as a Social Security
Administration trainee was taught that
one of the great benefits of the Social
Security system was at stabilizing
effect on the economy and its moderating
the business cycle effects on the
economy so it's astonishing astounding
even to see the idea of proposing that
part of the social security tax be put
into the stock market which seems to me
would likely increase the volatility
volatility exactly the volatility of the
stock market and the business cycle
wonder if you'd like to comment on that
and the pressure is behind it the
dynamics of trying to get this thing
path yeah I mean I think it's a really
good yet another good argument for
Social Security you know the bad
argument about Social Security is a
regressive tax it hits the lower lowest
of incomes and you know many people you
know for example uh undocumented aliens
have to pay Social Security and then
they never get any benefit from it but
you know particularly the the worst
thing about it is that it it puts a tax
it puts it a flat tax on people who
really shouldn't have to pay any taxes
but that's a big benefit of it and some
kind of social security system you know
has to be there has to be there it does
seem stupid to use it as a way of
actually creating more volatility i I'm
not quite sure if I can reconstruct the
an argument I heard a few weeks ago a
few months ago but i believe that
Benjamin barber said that in in a group
that I was in that national corporations
are susceptible to certain kinds of
regulations that can be put upon them by
national government but multinational
corporations are another thing because
they have sort of multiple national
constituencies and ownership and there's
no government governance body that can
regulate them
so the optimism about the sort of
external players dealing with that kind
of corporate body is is a problem is
that said something agree that is a real
problem because what they've created is
these things once called the World Trade
Organization one's called NAFTA now
they've extended it they're negotiating
the free trade agreement of the americas
NAFTA's is much more severe agreement
than the world trade organization and
its what's becoming the hemispheric
model well what it says is that they've
created these these non elected bodies
these sort of their supposed to be
bodies of experts and a corporation can
actually sue a government and it can say
to the government this law of you would
you call a pollution law is really just
a disguised way of protecting your local
producers this is a restraint of trade
they don't have to argue that in an you
know in a traditional court setting
these tribunals are secret and they're
really not that accountable so they can
suddenly find a government for a
pollution law this has actually happened
in mex you know there was a merican
company that got hit by a mexican
environmental law they opened up a toxic
waste stop then they felt the mexicans
had changed the rules on them they don't
like it they went they took their case
to the NAFTA tribunal it met secretly
and they want they got 9 million dollars
I went and looked at their balance sheet
I thought no this would be an
interesting company to look at to invest
in I wonder if they're a good company or
not they're only profit was this 9
million dollar settlement so um yeah you
know that's a way of sort of taking
power away from Democratic legislators
like the Mexican parla you know the
Mexican whatever it's called you know
that it was a slow chol government that
had put that a rule on the company
unexpectedly after the national
government had negotiated with the
company company said that the national
government should come in and overrule
the local government that was the issue
but and all those kinds of things are
really ways of smoothing the road so
that international business can happen
you could argue that those things are
necessary for for for free trade but you
can also argue that many ways they're
bringing all of the pollution and laws
down to the lowest common denominator
and it's sort of happy it happened in
the United States the way that state
control
of corporations was sort of weakened in
the late 1800s was this thing called a
race to the bottom new jersey and then
Delaware decided they were going to go
for the whole other way they're going to
make it completely easy for corporations
and once they had done that other states
couldn't really maintain their standards
everybody had to go down to the lowest
common denominator so now that's
happening at international level now
that the party now we have highs I think
we're winding up here but I had one
observation I wanted to make it maybe
you could elaborate on you have a
wonderful little vignette towards the
end of your book about the Dominican
none in Houston who went to the exxon
mobil annual meeting a couple of years
ago and tell me tell that story yeah
well I was down in Texas and I was in
Dallas and I went to the exxon mobil
annual meeting and it was a very
dramatic exchange between the the
chairman of ExxonMobil the CEO oh yeah
Lee Raymond and this dominican none and
basically she said you know we're I
represent about 80,000 clergy and nuns
and we want we want a we want to
maximize profits but we don't want to
totally maximize profits we'd like Exxon
to also come up with some accountability
in terms of what is it doing about
global warming what are its policies
with regard to its employees and it was
very dramatic because the response of
the Chairman was and he was really blunt
and really rude but it didn't put the
issue in stark contrast he said really
anything you have to say is irrelevant
because the issue has already been
decided by proxies that I have here in
my pocket so and then he said but you
have 45 seconds so keep saying whatever
you want you know well the point is that
it's important for us to do that and we
are to a certain extent an hour
Unitarian Universalist Association the
way we buy stock and this is this is a
you know responsibly responsible
ownership of stock and I think many
other religious institutions are as well
and that's a small but a very important
way of grabbing ahold of these you know
wild bulls yeah you know and even though
her proposal was only getting a few
percent she was managing to shine light
on an aspect of the way the company runs
that actually a lot of other investors
weren't too comfortable with either
which is basically the fact that the
management had run away with a company
thank you gangs of America is published
by berrett-koehler for more information
go to BK connection com